[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about one of the most mysterious
characters in attack on Titan we are
going to be talking about the Boy Wonder
Zeke Yeager himself in the attack on
Titan guide books he got an
off-the-charts score in intelligence and
11 out of 10 making him the smartest
character in the series along with hanji
Zoe
today we are going to pick the brains of
this Brainiac and explore the philosophy
of the seek Yeager if you want to see
more attack on Titan videos on this
channel make sure to warhammer smash
that like button to let me know and
suggest future attack on Titan videos
you'd love to see in the comments if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and bring
that notification bell so you don't miss
any new videos
there will be manga spoilers in this
video so in the paraphrased words of
Morpheus this is your last chance after
this there is no turning back
you take the blue pill the story ends
you click off the video and believe
whatever you want to believe you take
the red pill you stay in Wonderland and
I show you how deep the rabbit-hole goes
first things first what do I mean when I
say philosophy well simply put
philosophy is a way of thinking about
the world the universe and society
although we may all live in the same
objective world our view of that same
world is framed by our subjective
ideology or belief system for instance
my cousin and I experienced rain
differently I don't like when it's
raining because it means I can't run
outside I'll get what if I go out
anywhere and I simply feel better when
the sun is shining and the skies are
clear and calm however my cousin loves
the rain she gets excited when it starts
raining and prefers it to a bright shiny
day are either of us objectively writing
our response is rain objectively good or
objectively bad the truth is rain is
rain it's just doing its thing it's
neutral but depending on the person or
context we turn into a negative or
positive thing different perspectives
mean that we will view the same events
or the same world differently we see
this in attack on Titan all the time
attack on Titan is not just a battle
between Titans shifters it's a battle
between conflicting ideologies different
characters are fighting because they
have
and philosophies they each believe that
their way of viewing the world is the
right way or at least right enough for
them to fight for it and whoever wins
will proceed to shape the world
according to their philosophy at first
the world view within the walls was a
pretty simple one humanity had to defeat
these evil villains slowly but surely
this worldview was complicated they
figured out that some humans could turn
into Titans which complicated the
distinction between us humanity and then
the Titans then this was further
complicated by the fact that some survey
corps members like Annie Ryder and Beth
told actually appeared to side with the
Titans rather than with humanity
the basement was my favorite part in the
whole series because of the huge
worldview shift that took place after
our main characters discovered the truth
of what's happening beyond the walls for
the longest time we thought that all
that was left of humanity was inside the
walls and the villains were the Titans
however in the basement we find out that
there is human life beyond the island
and the people there are even more
technologically advanced the people of
Marlay appeared to be enemies while the
Titans turn out to have been humans
specifically fellow LD ins who were
usually unjustly punished and forced to
become Titans against their will however
it's not even as simple as saying the
marlins and their warriors like Reiner
and Berthold are the villains we get to
see the Marlay in perspective and we
find out that the LDN Warriors were
brainwashed from a young age to believe
the island dwelling LD ends are Devils
who must be killed so that the good LD
ends will stop being hated not only that
but the families of the Warriors are
pretty much hostages that the Marlon
government can use to keep the Warriors
from turning on them so the Marlins who
use the audience seem like the bad ones
except we find out that they used to be
oppressed by the LD ins and that there
are Marlins who actually care about
Marley and LD ins every time we think we
have a villain in this series
ISA Amma shows us their perspective and
in doing so refuses to give us a
black-and-white story about good guys
versus bad guys now let's see if this
can be applied to the beast
the monster who killed countless people
and even appear to take joy in it during
the Battle of XI Ghanshyam district he
is killing people by throwing rocks at
them and he treats it like a game he
acts like he's just playing baseball and
says he's going for a perfect game he
also says the first pitch is just a
warm-up for him an attack that killed a
number of human beings was not framed as
a brutal act of murder but as a warm-up
for a game he's playing could you say
i'ma possibly make us empathize with
such a seemingly evil cold-blooded
character to answer this question we
have to turn to the life of Zeke Jaeger
to the boy who would one day become the
Beast Titan and slaughter all of these
people Zeke was born - Grisha Jaeger in
the Libero internment zone outside of
the wall in Marlay the LD ants are
discriminated against because of their
ability to turn into Titans something
only LD ins can do a lot of people feel
justified in treating LD ends cruelly or
even killing LD and children because
they don't view them as fellow humans
but as monsters an officer fed Grisha
sister two dogs when they were both
still children and he got away with it
which paints a picture of just how
incredibly unfair the treatment of lb
ins can be because of his identity
surroundings and experiences Grich had
developed a hatred for Marlins and a
desire to restore the LD an empire he
wanted audience to rule over other
people's like they once did he worked
with others who felt the same way and
the group was fittingly called the LD n
restorationist then he married Deena
Fritz and L Dean with royal blood and
had Zeke to oversimplify the matter
Grisha was a bad father to Zeke he
didn't treat him like a human like an
individual who should have the freedom
to choose his own path from the
beginning he viewed him as a chosen one
who will one day lead the audience to
victory
when he found out about The Warrior
Program where Marlins were looking for
child LD ins to use as Titan weapons
Grisha was quick to volunteer his young
son even though he was so young Grisha
put the pressure of being a double agent
and L Diaz only hope on Zeke's shoulders
but before that child Zeke regularly
experiences criminy
for being LDN we get a flashback up
Grishka Deena and Zeek looking off a
roof where they have permission to be
and I'm are layin worker splashes them
with water
he says he's renting the place of its
filth and he thinks that LD ins are
demons who taint everything he calls
them descendants of the devil who
Massacre every last thing they could and
then he claims it's only natural for
them to be exterminated he looks at Zeke
and is disgusted that Grisha and Deena
would give birth to another devil Zeke
is crying because of the verbal abuse
remember he's experiencing this at a
very vulnerable and impressionable age
and this is just one example of what he
must have been experiencing throughout
childhood still Zeke was the opposite of
Aaron where Aaron was committed to
killing all Titans at a young age
Zeke actually lacked conviction while
other children in the program worked
desperately to become our layin warriors
Zeke didn't have the same Drive and lag
behind the others we see that he was
regularly neglected by his parents
Chris's father told his son and Deena
that Zeke missed them but they kept on
prioritizing the LD and restorationist
s-- to their own son Zeke's intelligence
was clear from a young age he was able
to learn about the LD and restorationist
version of history but pretend that he
was being taught the Marlin version of
history he even kept a secret from his
grandparents telling them that Grisha
was teaching him the same things they
learned at school even though it was
clear that Zeke was unhappy with the
warrior program and didn't really want
to be a warrior except to get the praise
of his parents he continued to tell his
grandparents that he did want to become
a warrior during the time period where
he was constantly getting singled out at
the warrior training for having no Drive
he ran into the user of the beast Titan
Tom Xavier tom was like the father Zeke
never had one who actually paid
attention to him his feelings and was
willing to play catch with him
he didn't just music as a tool like his
father did he viewed him as a child with
his own feelings who he really cared
about the scene of them playing catch
was juxtaposed to the next few panels
where an excited Zeke rushes home to
talk to his father only to get shut down
and ignore it again because Grisha had
LD
restorationist business at this point
the LD and restoration has decided that
their only chance is to get Z to inherit
the beast Titan and to partake in the
mission to take back the founding Titan
Grisha left a crying Zeke to live
full-time with the Marlin military so
he'd have a better chance of becoming a
warrior again he put ridiculous pressure
on his son never thinking about or
caring to notice how he may be feeling
or what he really wants she even tried
before to talk his parents out of the LD
and restorationist business he told them
to stop doing dangerous things or
they'll all be sent to Paradise Island
and turned into Titans Grisha slams a
table which scares Zeke bringing tears
to his eyes he claims that a sister Fay
Zeke's aunt died because of how crazy
the world is and that they have to fight
so that no one ever meets her fate again
while Zeke mentions his grandfather's
view which is that they died because
they went outside the walls that day
because they broke the rules again we
have another case of clashing
philosophies the same event phase death
is framed in two ways one is that the
unfairness of the world needs to be
fixed through any means necessary so
that this doesn't happen again while
another is that LD ins need to find
whatever happiness they can while living
within the walls and not breaking the
rules
both Grisha and his father don't want
something like what happened to fade to
happen again but they have radically
different ways of making that happen
Zeke seems to side with his grandfather
but still goes through with the Warrior
Program against his own will for his
parents when Zeke overhears that the
Marlin officials are closing in on the
LD and restorationist he has resigned
himself to him and his family getting
caught and being punished it is Tom the
father figure Grisha could never be who
tells Zeke to accuse his parents he
tells him it's his only option that way
he can even save his grandparents
otherwise they'd all die even the
grandparents who were adamantly against
rocking the boat Zeke says he could
never do that but Tom points out how
awful his parents were to him they use
Zeke for their own reckless plan putting
a seven-year-old
boy and his grandparents in mortal
danger Tom convinced esand that his
parents weren't concerned for him and
that they never loved him and finally a
7-year old Zeke ends up selling out his
parents later after everything he's
experienced in older Zeke wonders if it
would be best if the founding Titan
which can rewrite the bodies of subjects
of yamir could be used to make it so
that those same subjects could no longer
have children that way every Titan would
be gone in a hundred years and the world
wouldn't have to live in fear of titans
or suffer at their hands and he says
above all if we'd never been born in the
first place we never would have had to
suffer he becomes even more committed to
this plan when he hears Tom's story
about how his wife found out that he was
an LVN and then proceeded to slit her
own throat
and that of his child he became a
warrior because he wanted to kill
himself to end the suffering
despite the fun he's had with Zeke he
still thinks it would have been better
if he was never born
then Zeke promises to inherit the beast
Titan retake the founder and free the
world from the fear of the Titans and
the LD ins from their suffering for Zeke
L Diaz euthanization is the most just
and merciful goal so now we have a
better idea of how he could kill all
those soldiers during the Battle of
shegaon Sheena he was unfazed because in
the framework of his philosophy he was
freeing them of suffering and not only
that but their deaths would mean that he
could free many more lives from
suffering Zeke believes that life is a
curse for LD ins life is bad full of
suffering and the best thing to do is to
help the most amount of people possible
by making sure that LD ins and
subsequently Titans are phased out of
this world leave I hate Zeke because his
philosophy is that life is worth living
despite the suffering will talk about
exception later but in general Levi
wants to survive and to help his friends
survive as long as possible this is why
he views Zeke's actions as bad evil and
any other negative term you can throw at
them however as Zeke mentions in his
view he saved the people he killed and
the lives of the children
they would birth from this cruel world
every person he quickly killed with his
rocks at that moment he freed them of
all the suffering they would have had to
experience during the remainder of their
lives for Zeke the good in life at least
for LD ins is extremely outweighed by
the bad making death more appealing than
life and this is what good writers do
they don't give us a black-and-white
story where a guy who is a villain is
also clearly a villain even in his own
mind
no yama shows us how from the villains
own view he is a hero going after his
own version of the good going after his
own version of justice at first it might
be easy to side with Levi but remember
that even Levi felt a similar kind of
way at one point when his best friend
Irwin was on the brink of death and he
could have potentially saved him by
giving him two Titan serum and having
him eat the colossal Titan he decided
not to because letting him die was
freeing him from hell he decided to let
him rest rather than call him back into
the cruel world of attack on Titan so
although they are on different sides
it's not like Levi's never been able to
see things from Zeke's perspective from
the perspective that it could
potentially be better to die than to go
on living in this cruel world so let me
know what you think of Zeke can you
empathize with the character do you
think he's a good villain
or would you not even classify him as a
villain if you know anything about me
you'll know that I completely disagree
with Zeke I like to think of myself as
an optimist I believe that although
suffering is inevitable in life we can
always find enough meaning and happiness
to make it worth living if we don't give
up obviously I haven't personally
experienced as much suffering as a lot
of the characters in attack on Titan but
I still find myself siding with
characters who although they've suffered
keep moving forward striving to create a
better future on earth for themselves
and their loved ones if we consider LD
ins to be their own race we can say that
Zeke has internalized the racism that is
targeted towards the ldiots he has
adopted the view of that man who
splashed water on him and his family so
long ago
Zeke's train of thought is something
like this LD ins become Titans Titans
are bad and kill a lot of people people
fear Titans people hate LD ins people
treat LD ends cruelly no one is happy LD
and should cease to exist my major issue
with zis philosophy besides it being a
pessimistic one is that Zeek feels
justified in deciding what's best for
other people just as Grisha unfairly
tried to force Zeek to adopt his
philosophy Zeek is doing the same Grisha
should have recognized seeks
individuality respected his feelings and
given him the freedom to choose his own
path in the same way Zeek should
recognize the individuality of other LD
UNS respect their own feelings and give
them the freedom to choose what they
want who is Zeek to the side that is
merciful to kill an LDN shouldn't that
Aldean be able to decide for him or
herself if they want to live if life has
Worth if the good outweighs the bad for
them I have major issues with the fact
that Zeek forces his own philosophy on
others stripping them of their freedom
to choose
besides why does ich think that the
technological innovations that are
supposed to surpass the power of the
Titans soon won't make life just as bad
as the Titans made it or worse in my
view it is naive to think that getting
rid of LD ins and Titans will solve
everyone else's problems sure they may
live in fear of titans now but even
after the titans are gone they will have
to live in fear of weapons of mass
destruction despite my issues with what
appears to be Zeke's philosophy at this
point I think that ISA yama does a good
job of illustrating how the world is not
black and white everyone is fighting an
attack on titan for what they believe is
good and what that good looks like is
often influenced by their own tragic
backstories in my view Zeke's actions
are completely unjustified nevertheless
Yama does a good job of humanizing the
beast Titan user who seemed like the
incarnation of pure evil when he was
introduced earlier in the series but let
me know what you think do you think that
Aaron could ever truly adopt this kind
of philosophy especially since he and
the attack Titan seemed to always value
freedom above all else and that is it
for today's video thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed the video make
sure to go be smote on that like button
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss any new attack on Titan videos
remember to follow us on Instagram for
more content and crucial attack on Titan
updates thank you so much for your
support and until next time see you
space Cowboys
[Music]